hemos hablado mucho sobre células en
general pero lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es enfocarme en las células
vegetales muy bien todo este vídeo
tendrá que ver con las células vegetales
muy bien y en particular quiero
centrarme en lo que es la pared celular
de las células vegetales así que lo que
tenemos aquí abajo es justamente un
dibujo de una célula vegetal verdad y
quizás notes que en lugar de dibujar el
digamos el típico la típica figura de
una célula que es más o menos redonda
verdad en realidad ahora ahora he
dibujado esta forma digamos como como si
fuera un cubo o mejor dicho es es un
prisma rectangular verdad y la razón de
esto es que las células vegetales pueden
tener esta estructura así que que la
pregunta inmediata es qué es lo que les
da esta forma qué es qué es lo que les
permite tener una forma de prisma
rectangular y la respuesta es justamente
esta estructura verde que tenemos que es
la
pared celular muy bien entonces esto de
aquí es la pared celular
se le da muy bien y vamos vamos a
orientarnos correctamente en el dibujo
así que hay que hay que tener cuidado
por ejemplo si no tuviéramos este corte
que he hecho aquí en en las células
verdad simplemente veríamos el exterior
que es que es la pared celular verdad
pero justo debajo de la pared celular
tenemos lo que es la membrana celular de
la cual ya hemos hablado en vídeos
anteriores
esta es la membrana celular y dentro de
la membrana celular está contenido
digamos todo el citoplasma verdad está
contenido el citoplasma y ahí tenemos
esta estructura grande que está como en
color morado o en azul oscuro oscuro
verdad y esta estructura de aquí es una
vacuola verdad esto que tenemos aquí es
una
hola y es justamente verdad la
combinación de esta presión interna de
las cosas como la vacuola y todo el
fluido enrique que tenemos dentro es
digamos todo este fluido empuja hacia
afuera verdad y si le sumamos la pared
celular que lo mantiene todo junto
entonces eso es lo que les da a las
plantas a las células vegetales verdad
su estructura y en parte es por esto que
las plantas son capaces de crecer como
lo hacen entonces por ejemplo si
nosotros tratamos de pintar una planta
verdad aquí tenemos digamos un tallo y
aquí tenemos sus hojas de hecho estoy
viendo una una planta que tengo justo
enfrente de mí verdad pues más o menos
intento dibujarlo verdad entonces las
plantas son capaces de crecer digamos de
esta forma verdad y es y en parte las
razones por lo que acabamos de mencionar
verdad también tenemos otro tipo de
organismos dentro de la célula verdad
tenemos estos órganos los verdes que son
cloroplastos y que son fundamentales
para llevar a cabo la foto sin
también tenemos las mitocondrias que son
uno de uno de mis organelos favoritos
verdad aquí tenemos la membrana nuclear
digamos interna verdad y tenemos el adn
dentro de ella verdad aquí por ejemplo
tenemos el retículo endoplasmático y
podemos distinguir el retículo
endoplasmático rugoso que es en donde
tenemos los ribosomas verdad que son
estas bolitas y también tenemos el
retículo liso verdad que es en donde
justamente no tenemos los ribosomas por
otro lado tenemos el aparato de golgi y
en fin todo esto es como una especie de
repaso pero aquí nos vamos a enfocar en
la pared celular así que volvamos
digamos digamos a esta figura ok y aquí
por ejemplo podemos hacer un
acercamiento de este de esta pequeña
sección de la pared celular verdad así
que vamos vamos a fijarnos muy bien en
este acercamiento que tenemos y quizás
esta imagen verdad del acercamiento
podría sorprenderte porque al menos
no sé digamos cuando cuando yo me
imagino una pared pienso en algo
impenetrable verdad pero esta imagen nos
muestra algo completamente distinto aquí
aquí por ejemplo acá abajo tenemos la
membrana celular verdad esto de aquí
sería la membrana celular voy a hacerlo
con el mismo color
esto de acá sería la membrana celular
verdad y encima de ella está la pared
celular verdad encima está la pared
celular y si ves no son ladrillos
gruesos sino que hay como hay hay fibras
de polisacáridos verdad aquí tenemos por
ejemplo la celulosa verdad la celulosa
que es un polímero de la glucosa verdad
acomodado de cierta forma y podemos
encontrar otro tipo de estructuras por
ejemplo hechas de celulosa o podemos
encontrar también pectina muy bien y
probablemente hayas comido de esto
verdad en esta semana verdad así que
cuando pensamos por ejemplo en una dieta
con fibra en realidad estamos hablando
de cosas como como celulosa y pectina
verdad son cosas que tú
no puede producir verdad pero que ayuda
a por ejemplo alentar la absorción de
glucosa en los intestinos ayuda a
absorber agua y quizás otro tipo de
funciones de verdad la clave central
aquí quizás sea digamos mencionar que la
pared celular no es un muro impenetrable
como como no sé quizás el que tienes
enfrente de ti en tu habitación sino en
realidad aquí hay como espacio verdad
para que las moléculas pequeñas puedan
fluir verdad y entonces podríamos pensar
a la pared celular más bien como una
especie de rejilla verdad podemos ver
que que la membrana celular tiene acceso
al fluido que hay alrededor verdad a las
moléculas pequeñas verdad que se
encuentran entre las células así que
digamos tan tan sólo de verlo podemos
ver aquí justamente la membrana celular
aquí tenemos nuestra pared celular
verdad aquí tenemos la pared celular y
podemos observar el espacio que hay
entre las células verdad y este este
tiene un nombre muy
y es justamente la alaminilla media
grada que correspondería digamos a este
tipo de espacios verdad la alaminilla
media sería todo este espacio entre las
células verdad entonces todo esto es
bastante interesante pero podrías
preguntarte qué tan dura puede llegar a
ser una célula verdad porque podrías no
sé de pensar que las plantas verdad que
si las plantas pueden crecer firmes esto
podría deberse a que la pared celular
les brinda cierta rigidez sin embargo la
respuesta de eso sería digamos más o
menos más o menos es así y en efecto les
da les da forma a las células verdad la
pared celular le da forma a las células
pero si dejas de regar una planta verás
que empieza a marchitarse y se verá más
o menos así verdad empieza a marchitarse
y se verá más o menos así verdad y eso
se debe a que en parte para como parte
de su habilidad para para mantenerse de
pie es por la presión interna de las
células pero también se debe a la pared
celular verdad
algunos de ustedes dirán que han visto
plantas más rígidas verdad por ejemplo
podrán decir que han visto árboles
verdad y los árboles tienen madera
verdad podríamos pensar en un árbol que
tiene mucha digamos tiene un tronco muy
muy firme hecho hecho de madera verdad y
uno se preguntaría bueno por qué es que
la madera es más rígida verdad bueno una
vez que la célula deja de crecer y tiene
ya su pared celular verdad se empiezan a
formar más capas de celulosa con otro
tipo de moléculas para así crear una
pared secundaria verdad y eso es lo que
le da más rigidez ok entonces por eso es
que aunque deshidrates la madera en
realidad ésta conserva su rigidez y es
debido a las capas de celulosa y otras
moléculas que se van formando muy bien
ahora de lo último que quiero hablar en
este vídeo es bueno ya hemos ya hemos
dicho que la membrana celular tiene
acceso a las moléculas verdad que flotan
alrededor o entre las células pero
también hay túneles
entre células vegetales adyacentes
verdad y los he dibujado con estos
pequeños puntitos amarillos que tenemos
aquí muy bien estos son digamos los
túneles que hay entre células adyacentes
y estos se llaman plasmo demás así que
aquí tengo un mejor dibujo de lo que es
un plasmo de esma
ok así que imaginemos que aquí tenemos
una célula 1 ok pensemos que esto es una
célula 1 esta es nuestra célula 2 muy
bien y estas son células adyacentes y
nosotros podemos distinguir los plasmó
demos como estas estructuras que pinte
digamos con magenta verdad y aquí
podemos observar estos pequeños pliegues
verdad estos pliegues de retículo
endoplasmático liso muy bien entonces
estos plas modernos son literalmente
túneles que conectan a las células
adyacentes muy bien podemos tener un
flujo de cito sol directamente entre
estas dos células y solo quiero insistir
en algo porque cuando esto
biología todo está explicado y parece
que es muy claro en los libros de texto
pero muchas personas siguen estudiando
exactamente por qué es que estas
estructuras son necesarias que puede ser
transportado a través de ella de estas
estructuras verdad y bajo qué
condiciones en realidad se pueden
transportar estas moléculas todas estas
preguntas en realidad son áreas verdad
son son parte de la investigación activa
de hoy en día así que espero que este
vídeo te dé una mejor idea de de las
plantas que tienes digamos a tu
alrededor de la madera que utilizas e
incluso de la ensalada que podrías comer
en el almuerzo